come some du or callers they come on the
same platform even though yes big man
say they have different
ideologies they say we're doing it for
the support of okay firstly no doubt we
have to
utilize any means as long as Hal to
support our brothers and sisters okay we
have to do that to Aid our brothers and
sister because what happen to oppression
no doubt about that you know but she
start cooperating with people Innovation
M guidance
many said that's not permissible why
that's that will cause confusion but now
saying that and I said it many times and
few people lying against me online
saying that now imagine all of us here
Muslims the enemies attack us you're
going to start asking are you are you
are you m what we do we fight back even
I said that many times yeah but people
still lie against me you know people
still lie you understand so the point
here is that yes we should not corporate
with Innovation guidance for claiming to
support we support we have our own
platform we expose what the Zionist are
doing K okay however when it comes to
fighting us if we live in a village and
and we have the power we fight back now
if we don't have the power and there's
no scape for us we still fight back if
because there's no Escape you understand
so alhamdulillah that's why my dear
brothers and my sisters may Allah bless
you
sh is back to CL the Quran andah until
now no one canat Quran andah everyone my
father told me my grandmother had dream
but even those guys they knew they
cannot fight me one one to one they had
to bring four people even with four
people they
knew you know I made du to Allah guide
them but even with four of them they had
a doubt we cannot beat CH we have to
deceive him what they said they said
Salam to me Salam you know islamically
if you say Salam to someone mean you are
protected to me
now they had to come behind me alhamd
I'm still here they made me stronger
than ever I'm back stronger than ever
alhamdulillah why I'm stronger from
Allah so alhamdulillah and you know what
is about me my enemies know me but I
don't know them so I'm walking the
streets the same guy probably who was
kicking my head you say to me I
sayum but you know Allah is watching and
you know is well because they knew they
done a bad job they had to put the last
clip when there was just even the kick
but before that the big guy was kicking
me I was gonna ask him brother did I
kill your father or something the was
kicking me you know you know I like to
my joke you know the last guy who tried
to punch me you see the punch he did
that last guy man I'll s come I will
give you
some anyway do have the prophet messages
to carry you on even there out there I
have to make this claimer somebody I
don't even know them they say we're on
the road we're not practicing it's your
business forgive make Dua it's your
business but we're on a job I said no
don't give you my name I said we don't
care you know but many people love me
aldah many people even practicing they
love aldah
Ian that's why I'm open to anyone come
and I've been doing it here I'm not
hiding I'm not J had this keyboard you
know there's too many J keyboard speak I
defend Palestine many times and guess
who and got Zionist four months ago
there certain things I said about
Zionism can put me in trouble but I
would say it because I believe is a
truth alhamdulillah so but anyway so we
don't have to start watering down to UTI
some people are utilizing
Gaza issue to justify the
misguidance we have to be careful
because you know have you noticed Islam
is spreading okay lot of people Islam
online the en Islam are watching have
you not noticed after Soviet Union was
created after Iraq and Sham is was
created now there's a new wave of
extremist going to create that they will
U the enemies of Islam going to use them
to try to make Islam look bad so we have
to be cautious we love Palestine
Philistine we love all every Muslim
country we want good for them we make
Dua for them but don't be my the parents
watch out your children you don't want
to be your child to be killing innocent
people in London then claiming his doing
for Philistine cuz extremist now are
back to life and like Coes the like what
Coes if you turn on the light they will
run away if you turn it off they come
back like these guys they attacked me in
dark all right so my point here
is yes we defend it alhamdulillah and
one of the lies or one of the brothers
contact me he loves me say I love
but how can you say because of deserve I
said can you show me where then he got
me video he put it up and I was talking
in general we were talking afterwards
what cause F in our countries sometimes
because it can be a test sometimes can
be punishment sometimes because of sins
like what happened to me it could be
sins it could be punishment it could be
a test I always deal with Quan
alhamdulillah so I was talking about sh
there Algeria the guy asked aboute I
said yes
doesn't mean every philistin is mus in
alia there's a sh there's a sh but
there's but the people now because
what's up in phe they took that bit try
to make me look bad but guess what I of
this incident you know how many people
are contacting me even non-muslims
asking but you know one thing made me
very sad you know the Beats it not
really hurt me you know what hurt me wor
when I've noticed the enemies of Islam
are utilizing that clip to make Islam
look better
that hurt me more than anything else
when how long we've been coming here to
make to refuse the doubt against Islam
to show that Islam is no what this kaj
try to portray now the en Islam and the
RAF are happy and every RAF saying
because he had that's what happened to
him the other one said because he had
Jesus you understand every person is
vomiting from his head you understand
said alhamdulillah Muhammad wasallam got
beat up by the AR
pagans so get
B by a group of people doesn't make you
good or bad there's no criteria the
criteria is it and all the time me
getting B doesn't make me righteous man
open the truth go back to Quran aldah
and that's why they don't like
it and but now that clip went
viral is exposure for me for the whole
world to know me and to know what is
calling to and one of the ISL one of the
far right what's his name or something
well he's a British first or you know
what his name I forgot about he huh poor
poor pooran yeah this guy put a moderate
IM he put it just to utilize in his
favor I'm a I believe sh Allah is the
best sh for every time in every place
you see what I'm saying so no no I
believe Islam is the best religion for
all the whole the world guess Zionist I
believe the Zionist are terrorists who
are killing our brothers and sisters in
Gaza so don't try to utilize my for your
favor but I still pray to Allah guide
you to the truth you know and to know
that Islam is free from those people are
innocent people in the
park understand alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah
see so those Brothers may Allah guide
you just look back step back say Okay We
R Who people are happy about it and ISL
so you people are
and hate Islam to be happy alhamdulillah
that's why your achievements therefore
you have to check your heart I you a
clear enemy of Allah and his Messenger
to make the enemies of Allah happy for
someone who Christianity Judaism
Hinduism sism liberalism atheism aldah
Allah give us sincity alhamdulillah you
know the now what we have to focus on
more like I said exposing
the
exposing and like exposing the
Z that's why we have to focus so we
don't have to to clarify the truth to
support our brother and sisters
alhamdulillah there's many ways to send
money by make sure the money is going to
the right people you know alhamdulillah
even I want to make clarification to the
Nation about specific situation because
it's an obligation from The Lord of the
creation so listen carefully you know I
like to R I'm an we love rhyming pay
great attention pay great attention
listen my dear brothers and sisters in
Islamic Nation what was going to say
they say Shi was mocking
Palestinians well anyone says that are
you ready to
come ask the hard one cuz you believe I
was moing the
Palestinian in the park online don't be
rat in the real life and lying behind
the
keyboard I'm moing my dear brother are
you mentally Disturbed I you been
smoking crack for a long time they don't
know what the heck you're talking about
I was talking about people who are
hypocrites you want to Bro Starbucks boo
Starbucks if you're doing it for Allah
may Allah reward you you understand but
just make sure you are sure about
something like don't like one brother I
was drink C coffee they said no they
supposed this too I said I'm going to
drink now I'm going to make my own
coffee as well if I make my own coffee
I'm using the water of the British and
they help the designers too
yes if I buy stuff from the shops the
the the tax money that I'm giving them
they're going to British government who
are given Happ design is too There Is No
Escape there's no escape from it there's
no Escape you understand so if you're a
boycott and you're doing it Allah reward
you but don't make the coffee equivalent
to the blood of of the Palestinians the
blood of the Palestinian is more
honorable than a coffee you understand
if you think a coffee is equivalent to
the blood of phe or any Muslim then you
must be enemy of Allah and his messenger
you must be hi Zionist because the blood
of the Muslim is more honorable so I was
not moing my dear brothers and sisters
I'm not moing and I was not moing and
but people think I'm still going to ref
the and expose the
and
nonstop just one thing Allah give
us that's the most important thing
man that's one thing that we should all
all of us like you know one brother
mentioned a good point he says they used
to Fe for themselves and then never used
to go around blame
everyone but now everyone's except them
Subhan Allah that shows you what no of
Allah those who make sex Muslim leaders
those who call the people to reel
against the Muslim leaders some of them
they are not every person does it some
of them are affected by it some are yeah
the those who love the Western World
they run from the Muslim countries
claiming the Muslim countries C if
someone ask say I don't believe Muslim
country CA I never run away from Algeria
because they arear so don't use me if
you run away from Algeria you tell me
because arear and you're Britain you
are what happened you went silence you
ask
question question recently I had brother
on my because the same allegations were
made about him and yourself he clarifi I
need I need clarify but still people are
still retweeting the same why because
why I believe there there was a stud
done recently now what's happening
because there's a war so many Muslim are
just emotional they're not thinking
you're not thinking he said it even bro
how can you J for example to make it
clear imagine now enemy of Islam comes
and said you know what in the and says
kill the kufar wherever you find them
what you going to tell him go back to
the text the context yes so why you
taking one minute clip and you going
back to the
context and you know who did that after
we had discussion with him in the park
he became mentally troubled literally he
became mentally troubled online sh sh he
said I stent these are fake what
happened this guy does not a vertigo
just me sitting on the floor I get dizzy
the way I was sitting let aone people
kick let alone people kick in me I know
I'm strong but I know I'm very strong
people finger I'm I'm strong you know
it's good to be good of
me but anyway so this person became
mentally he start spreading R against
me Allah Jud between us he's a liar he's
a my brother know he said he said the
seek care from the police brother put
video he never threaten him you know
what he did he start seeking help from
the
police the same guy who said if he's
moing sopies by saying you seek help
from the kuf no one threaten him no one
touch him he just got scared he said you
know what we need to go back to
police Allah you know what if you are
with Allah Allah will always Aid you lie
even you know what we feel our
sins alhamdulillah just
learn study our alhamdulillah and let me
clarify find another lies some people
say in Shi says if someone come to kill
you go read the Quran first a brother I
don't know who who sh you listening to I
can't remember saying that except if you
are listening to me listen to music same
time and drinking alcohol so I can't
help you guys what you going to say I
never said that in my life I never said
to people just stay there I he said he
said people they should defend
themselves regardless because they have
nowhere to go they have to fight you
understand but what is very sadden our
heart the people of dying more they
civilians what is that why why why they
not protecting them why they care about
their party more than the people of Raza
that's when you know sh he care about
the people of alhamdulillah but some
people they care about some parties More
Than People of
Gaz you know how on the Earth imagine
Prophet Muhammad in the war when the
Battle of why he said sah make sure you
go protect the women and
children prot
people If he canot if he cannot invol
them why that's why mentioned mentioned
they said if a leader will
get even with a war and let me clarify
to today is a day of clarification to
the nation they said said the
Hamas started the war yes okay if you
listen to the whole thing again I said
no doubt the Z start the war from before
they invade Palestine you understand
they invade what before yes no doubt
about just even even before that they
were killing people in in in no doubt
about that but I'm talking about proper
War ham themselves admitted it do you
know he said is well Muhammad hijab in
the show with P Morgan he said yes there
the war and he said H said it so why
have problem with me then if H said it
why you have problem with me you
understand that's my point
is mentioned that said if a leader go to
war okay any War defense or offense if
he's not able to protect the Muslims you
should not go you can't go back to it
okay you can't go back to
it what do you think about what do you
think
11,000 defend defend yourself you think
Improvement defend yourself and the
people said they defend themselves but
you know what is worse they have nothing
defend
themselves brother I'm saying defend I
do I kill myself BL I said go defend
myself I say go defend yourself you want
to
defend asking the same
question what do you mean to do what do
you me to do I mean SCH she be like the
Muslim re the Muslim anding
up brother
100% they should do but what we here in
Britain are we sure if going to unite
we're going to leave all of us leave
Britain question so no doubt the Muslim
leaders should come together no doubt
that's why make Dua to Allah unite the
Muslim leaders to defend our brother I
mean look the people talking about me
they're not doing more than me
alhamdulillah because I'm here defending
also we make Dua our every first
prayer accept it but
don't don't make do something extra not
doing nothing except barking online he
does he doesn't even meas to make Dua we
have a meas we do every more prayer they
doing Allah accept it so I'm saying
defend yourself not now defend yourself
defend yourself let them defend
themselves and make du for them and
expose if you have knowledge how to
expose Zionist and you have skills on
social media show how these Zionist are
murdering our brother and sister you
understand where did you go make
sense I didn't get no you know what is
happening now we talk in general okay in
general for example in general yes when
are you going to become
Muslim you like Muslims do you just
listen is
here like he's Jewish are you Zionist
don't going to kill you cuz you are
protected
here's a jewi guide him man and then
from long time for 10 years gu
him you know make for them now me anyone
that screw with me my brothers if you
screw my point or anything or you heard
something online come forward and make
sure Quran is between between
us I don't know everything I can be
wrong many times I made mistake many
times in my life but
ask that's why when the called me they
said look you live that lifestyle you
are now you give so you are open to
discussion of course someone come to
attack me try my best to defend myself
not for please if you want to attack me
again just one please now come on Happy
brother just one what I tell you attack
me don't hug me and stop me okay anyway
so so Subhan Allah he like be patient
you know ask Allah to guide them and
open discussion you are there to give
that alhamdulillah alhamdulillah man so
if any if you think I made mistake or
something I was wrong you're more than
welcome to say look I believe you made
mistake in there like you know like the
brother said to me you mock them about
Starbucks I said show me I said go back
to the video you he went back he said I
apologize he said you know I made the B
I made a bad comment about you I'm going
to correct it I said ald Allah gave you
to go back and watch the whole video the
thing
was Islam gives you that right to ret to
to retaliate to to fight back retaliate
retaliate to ret retaliate yes my tongue
twisted however if you overlook and
forgive and and pardon them and make Dua
for them it's much better as well you
understand but on the condition they
don't carry you on because like I said
I'm I'm a person of Da you understand
and of course I'm not the best example
to follow I'm saying this but maybe if I
see yeah but I'm not the best person
like I'm no real because why I have my
like if I see them maybe the alerian
craziness kicks
off
understand would you classify
as a no I never call
him I had some SCH I don't care
which no one I I never in my life how I
never in my life
okay what do you think about someone
praising
army army who killed sunnis in in in and
Syria and he praised
them then I'm asking you brother what do
you think about someone praising someone
who killed the sunnis in sham because
why I've noticed W my dear brothers and
sisters some Muslims they don't care
about the Muslims all they care about
specific people that want to utilize
them for their agenda watch this what do
you think about the Muslims that was
killed
by which is a sh sect in Iraq
and in Syria what do you think about
someone praising them and he
said Brothers what do you think what do
you someone praise the murderers pra
someone who killed the sunnis in Iraq
and Sham that's crazy that's crazy no
that's yeah okay you know who knows it
who it it's online you can't it's not
fake everything ham the leader of ham
they praised him but now no no it's okay
the sunn like he's like forget about
sunis in Iraq and Sham that's why I know
many Iraq and Sham they coming out and
say What About Us my brothers and sister
around the world why don't you care
about us who being
killed Subhan Allah but now I'm with
every Muslim in Gaza fighting against a
Zionist for Allah's sake not for his
party for Allah's sake listen carefully
and with anyone in Gaza fighting for
Allah's sake against Zionist
not question from you on because why
I've noticed this question like that you
have answered my question to show you
they don't care about
the that's I show you what they do if
the party that is fighting It Go in line
with the agenda for example I'll give
you scholar Sunni Scholars always speak
the truth when the people rebelled
against Algerian government some salvis
did it as well and they
called said you're wrong what you did
they didn't say oh you're wrong they
say he said even that you don't have the
power you have the ability you're
wrong because some people say if there
were I'm fighting you praise them
but
subh even some people mocking me when I
got very angry about my brothers and
sisters being killed
in I show you some people don't deceive
you say oh because of Starbucks because
of this all that lie because sh Quran
and people who some of them don't like
Quran
andah that's why look I'm not hiding I'm
not covering my face am I I'm everywhere
alhamdulillah and I talk to anyone come
alhamdulillah we spoke to to Christians
the people that attack me they don't
like because
IAH may Allah guide
them they try to utilize
ghost not just online okay what tell me
what I said is
wrong um you Tred to
say I said
what I heard yeah that's why you heard I
never said first show you a clip see
he's proving my point he showed him a
clip and may Allah bless you for asking
the question firstly I don't believe
country called Israel I believe country
called festine secondly how on the earth
someone who's fighting and din in the
park in Britain he's going to if you
want to boycot Israel so- Israel boycot
them yeah you want to boycot them boyot
them how can we boycot them
now no no how can we boycott them no no
how can you Bo them no brother how
can them I said you want to boy them boy
them how can we boy them the
question doing Collective action colle
together yeah boy watch Boy watch so if
um for example I don't go Marx Spencer
because I have clear proofs Max Spencer
they have zist but I don't force on him
if I see Max spener I don't get because
that's my personal choice you understand
I don't make it like pill of Islam like
some people know if you drink Costa
Coffee you're a Believer if you drink
Starbucks you're C so Costa Coffee makes
you believer you understand like I I
don't go because I have a clear proof
Max SP is a Zer supporter I don't go
there aldah but I don't force on people
if I see a brother going to Max I yeah
maybe M maybe this that's my point and I
mentioned that many times because also
in the you want to do it doah but my
problem is when you start accusing your
Muslim brother and sister if they don't
follow what you follow you understand
even though they make Dua they cry and
all of that no because because now
maxens like for example if I see a
brother making Dua for defending
refuting zist could do everything and I
said to him no no I don't think you I
think you're why because you don't boy
my Spencer but that's that's not the end
of it brother you know people who are
working some of your tax money is going
toward the government and the government
is paying F how you going to they like
when I said are you going to stop
working they don't like it when I said
to stop working we have to
in that's what I'm saying
stop you know what should you even buy
from buy anything from the shops because
somehow when you buy something the shop
is paying what you're part of the system
you're part of the system you're paying
tax yeah exactly you're going to say
something you canot escap it we cannot
do this we have to do we have to do
certain things we can no what I'm saying
what I'm
saying that's what say I'm coming to it
when you're
Starbucks those are
obvious okay your tax is not obvious
it's obvious no no obvious obvious your
tax
money to
okay me look I'm going to play that now
if someone says to you if someone says
to you Starbucks is franchised so not
all the money go to Z go somewhere else
so my intention I'm going to pay them to
for that money to go somewhere
else I like you shake your hand for that
good point you see saying but the point
is that's my point if you want you want
to boycott even whatever you like if but
you have proof cuz what's happening
sometimes now some companies are
accusing other companies to be what Z
supporter and they Bo them but in the
reality the other the other ones are
supporter yeah you know what I'm saying
so they drag customers to their compan
if you're doing it for Allah's sake you
do it but have Clear Proof according to
my knowledge but I'm not going to force
you and I start doubting IM I start
doubting this that's why that's why some
schol said to make a very very
um powerful to do it like um Collective
all of all of us together not just all
of us for example now for example if we
do on Max Spencer yeah Marx Spencer shut
down it's not going to affect Israel or
soal Israel is not why because 2 weeks
ago America gave 14 billion to whom and
remember this these big companies don't
pay taxes
well you know they don't
taxes you know the problem is in our we
have to be careful don't let children
online start dictating to us what should
we
do don't let our emotion children do
this do that we have to be careful just
make sure if you want to boycott like I
said me personally I boycott Max Spencer
because I'm on opinion I don't have to
seek permission from the leader even I
said it before people still saying are
you going to fight back or you going to
ask the leader brother how dumb can you
be how dumb I said it many times yes
there's other opinion they said you have
to wait for the leaders but us living in
the western world there's no Muslim
leader so you can do it by yourself but
also make sure don't don't be the best
friend of Shan you eat with Shan you
sleep with Shan you watch Dirty movie
Shan everything with Shan you don't pray
then you D the word about
boycotting make sure you boycott Shan
first
so that's my advice and sisters and also
us alhamd now we can pray night prayer
now okay we can pray night prayer
alhamdulillah make sure you wake up for
the night and make Dua for your brother
and sister Allah bless you all my
brother and sisters and may Allah our
brother and S and may Allah give us
Victory and may Allah protect the musl
from theil from the misguidance of the
and the
Zionist amen and